militia units from the self-declared
Donetsk People's Republic moving through
what's left of mariopol Ukrainian forces
surrounded preparing for what they call
today the final battle and even these
russian-backed separatists admit it's
been a hard fight
um
foreign foreign
positions Russia's foreign minister told
State tv there would be no let up in the
fighting is
straight from a visit to Ukraine where
he saw for himself the horrors of
butcher Austria's Chancellor arrived in
Moscow the first European leader to meet
with Vladimir Putin since this special
military operation as Russia insists on
calling it began
I have no optimistic impression that I
can bring you from this conversation
with President Putin the offensive is
obviously being massively prepared but
therefore also the clear commitment that
a stable access of the International Red
Cross is needed
Austria is one of Europe's few neutral
countries and its new chancellor has
made clear that that is not going to
change whatever the broader threat
as Finland and Sweden look towards
possible NATO accession themselves the
Kremlin today issued a warning saying
that that would not contribute to
European security
Russians have rallied behind their
president over these past six weeks his
approval ratings even with independent
pollsters now at more than 80 percent
age
are you worried about what's happening
in Ukraine what Russia is doing
foreign
foreign
but it will still be some time before
the economic squeeze from sanctions
really kicks in and when it does the
Kremlin will have one message for its
people however untrue that is that none
of this was our fault
Dynamic day Sky News Moscow